- The Monday rant video
was reverse engineered.
I just knew that people
would want to watch it.
And that's what I also think
is going to happen here.
Basically I want this film
to give you the audacity
to actually go out and do it.
You're 52 years old and
it's not being talked about
enough that hey man,
hey gal, it's not over.
If you want it so bad,
if it's in you,
maybe it's not time
to take up golf or
pack it in, maybe it's time
to actually triple down
and really focus on your
7 P.M. to 2 in the morning.
There's so many
people that truly are
good entrepreneurs or have
entrepreneurial DNA
but they just weren't lucky
enough to be born during an
era that that seemed practical.
It's hard for somebody
who's for 30 years gone
a certain blueprint to
understand that this
is that realistic and they feel
like it's a young man's sport
and it's just not.
Like, it's just not.
If you've got the right DNA and
you're a 72 year old female
you have just a good as an
at-bat as a 27 year old dude.
But you've been trained and
story told to and positioned
and lived in a
50 year matter that
doesn't feel like this
thing in here is
a practical way to
build that but it is.
The entrepreneurship
is not predicated on
taking away from your family.
Entrepreneurship is taking
away from everything else.
So stop making excuses,
"Oh these millenial kids
are so entitled."
"Oh, these kids didn't have
to work as hard as we did."
Nobody cares if you're 40, 70, 90
alien, female, male, minority.
The market will
accept your victories
if you're good enough
to have a victory.
And I believe, more than ever,
that if you're a 49 year old
housewife with two kids because
of this phone you've got more
opportunities to create
something for yourselves.
Please my friends, do not allow
just the 18 and 14 and
22 year olds to grab at this
pie that is so available to
all of us regardless of our age.
We're gonna live longer.
The opportunity is real.
The 58-year-old right now
that's watching this
you'll live another 40 years.
40 years of being able to do
something you love
is a big deal.
Start putting in the work,
start recognizing this isn't
just a young person's game.
Start representing the
people that actually
put in the work, the gray hairs
that context that knowledge.
Start deploying that. Educate
yourself on the new world.
Yes, you didn't grow
up with Instagram.
You didn't grow up driving
and you learned that.
Stop making excuses,
start getting educated
in the actual world and
start opening up
the opportunities.
In my true opinion, you
are actually more likely
to be successful in
building a company,
at 45, 50 today than the
18-year-olds that are coming out
because there's a naiveté,
a lack of experience.
You have experience,
you have experience.
Like, that's a real thing.
Cool, youth and
excitement is great,
you have actual
business experience.
Plenty amount of talent.
There's plenty amount of talent.
And there's a ton of
fire and bravado
and there's a confidence.
There's a confidence
that youth provides.
The difference between me
and so many of you is
I've put in the god damn
work to learn where
people's attention now is
and I'm deploying
myself through there.
Many of you have drawn
a line in the sand and
say I'm not
downloading Snapchat.
I'm not
downloading Instagram.
That, my friends, is going
to allow you to lose.
This video is made
for one reason:
I want it to be the calling
card, the seed of the explosion
of the 40 to 80-year-old
entrepreneur in our society.
The fire that I see in the
eyes of the 19, 20, 25-year-old
that feels that they're
entitled to this and
then on the flip side the
diminishing just a little
bit of ashes, a little smoke
left in that same entrepreneur
when they were 22 at 46 when
practicality and family dynamics
and the history and the market
tearing down and the lack
of that same opportunity
has just dwindled down
to a moment where
they don't believe
that they've got that shot.
I'm here to tell you
you absolutely do.
There are absolutely a ton of
entrepreneurs that started
their companies in
their 40s, 50s, 60s and 70s
when it was difficult
to do such a thing.
Sidney Frank who created
Grey Goose didn't invent
his big thing until his 70s.
And so I'm desperate,
I'm desperate to give you
a springboard to say
you know what
instead of watching
"House of Cards" seasons,
instead of trying to go
to ball games or
things of that nature,
yeah, I do have
7PM to 2 in the morning
Monday through Friday.
Heck, for a lot of you the
kids are out of the house.
I mean let's get
into practicality,
if the late 40s, 50s,
60-year-olds that are watching
this rant the kids
are out of the house.
Yeah, you could pick up golf
or you can finally start that
candle company because
you put pretty pictures
of candles on Instagram
and it happens.
Learn the craft.
Figure out the
opportunity at hand,
go attack it.
You only live once.
When you're 90 to 100-years-old
and you're regretting that you
never built this business
and you let this era pass
this moment where
there's so much
entrepreneurial upside,
you'll regret it and
regret is the worst.
That's what it is.
At least the way I see it.
I got home at
midnight last night.
And every fucking
night. It's just real.
I don't have to.
I don't know, I think
there's a real opportunity to
inspire a generation
that so deserves it.
I almost feel like being 40,
I feel like I'm caught
right in the middle.
I have so much empathy for,
I recognize how insane
I had to be to...
You can't even imagine
how not practical being an
entrepreneur was when
I was half your age.
In school, a 15 year old now
in school that's getting Ds but
is like selling shit on the
internet, everyone's like,
"Oh, you're the
next Mark Zuckerburg."
Mine was like, "Oh, you're
the next piece of shit."
You know? It's so
insanely different.
So I have a lot of
empathy for people that
I don't know if they
recognize how real it is.
(calm music)